this is it the last preview breakdown
for ahs double feature and as always
we're not gonna waste any time if you
haven't seen the preview i've left a
link to it in the description below but
please come back as i am so very lonely
here we are in the oval office and it
looks as though richard nixon might be
president you can see him getting ready
to sit down and the gentleman over here
by the door definitely isn't eisenhower
and we'll see ike in the hospital later
on with mimi doing some stitching on the
left of the frame ike says quote all of
this is them and we aren't quite sure if
he's referring to the aliens or nixon
himself after all nixon is a bit of a
shady character in american politics and
considering the reuters wrote him as
being the mastermind behind marilyn
monroe's death and that they've been
building up his ambition to one day
become president i wouldn't be surprised
if he could be involved for those of you
who are curious eisenhower died the same
year nixon took office here's nixon
looking concerned outside the window of
the oval we'll later see him praying
alongside who i believe could be henry
kissinger his secretary of state i
didn't take nixon for a religious man so
something quite dire must be going on
here now which of us hasn't been here
before it looks like someone is ready to
be probed my best guess nixon but it's
kind of tricky and did you notice the
two space aliens on the bottom right we
have mimi exiting a vehicle and valiant
thor explaining to nixon that the
creation of the hybrid would be a
complex task what's to keep him from
talking and revealing everything mimi
has been one of the biggest champions of
not letting the news of the aliens out
remember she always wanted ike to sign
that treaty with the aliens from day one
we don't really know who she's talking
to here this is area 51 and we get some
previously seen footage like amelia
earhart's x-rays surgical instruments
and the opening of the alien cadaver not
sure if they just put this in here to
pad the preview or if we'll be
revisiting some of these plot lines
here's someone getting out of a car at
area 51. i wonder if this guy's driving
mimi from the previous shot jaime says
what a pathetic race we turned out to be
which is probably the only thing she's
said so far this season that's made any
sense more reused footage until we come
across this here we see some armed
guards infiltrating what i think is area
51 judging by the shape indentations in
the wall valiant thor projects that the
very first functioning hybrid to be
ready around 2021 and it immediately
cuts to a shot of kendall's ultrasound
from episode 8. is this hinting that
kendall's child will be the first
functioning hybrid we have this guard
here wearing a full-on protective mask
not sure if that's because they're
hiding his or her identity or that it's
just part of the getup jamie and kendall
are startled and you can make out the
reflection of a flashing red light on
the right suggesting that someone or
something has broken into area 51
possibly to retrieve them mimi winks
nothing really game changing here but
check out these guards entering what i
believe to be the moon landing room from
area 51 that's because we'll later see
this shot of something attacking a guard
from up above set against the moon floor
or at least that's what it looks like to
me here's an interesting shot of nixon
and notice the round light on the top
right this is kind of what leads me to
him being the one that gets probed it
could be really interesting if nixon the
president of the united states was under
control of the aliens and finally one
final shot of an alien remember that
they really can't come down to earth
because according to mimi who was taken
over by them they haven't acclimatized
to the toxins and diseases of our planet
honestly i don't know how they're gonna
do so much in just one episode so like
any good ahs fan i get my hopes up
usually to be terribly disappointed
thanks for watching everyone be sure to
like and subscribe and for more bad
takes check me out on twitter and
instagram at think story yt until next
time remember daddy loves you very much
you